[Música]
buenas tardes muchísimas gracias por
estar aquí estoy súper feliz de estar
con ustedes
como les contaba yo desde hace casi dos
décadas he trabajado muchísimo con
biodiversidad cuando tenía ocho años yo
empecé a una actividad que se llama
observación de aves y la observación de
aves me llevó a un mundo impresionante
me abrió puertas que yo nunca me imaginé
que iba alguna vez a llegar y me he
vuelto una persona completamente
apasionada por la naturaleza y eso es lo
que les vengo a contar ahora como yo
creo que compartir esta pasión por la
naturaleza a través de un tema que se
llama ciencia ciudadana es
definitivamente el futuro de la
biodiversidad tanto para nosotros como
en general para todos los seres vivos
que están en el planeta el planeta
tierra
es un lugar impresionante si es que
ustedes ven al sistema solar van a
encontrar que de todos los planetas que
se encuentran en general todos los que
conocemos este tiene una característica
que no tiene ningún otro y es el
fenómeno de la vida no importa donde
ustedes pongan el dedo en la superficie
del planeta van a encontrar que la vida
ha cambiado esa superficie sea en el
agua sea en la tierra de hecho todo lo
que se ve ahí de hecho medio verdoso es
vegetación es un planeta el único que
hasta el momento conocemos que está
definido por el fenómeno de la vida
la vida es súper interesante porque
tiene un montón de formas de
adaptaciones que a lo largo de
aproximadamente unos cuatro mil millones
de años ha evolucionado en nuestro
planeta vamos a encontrar estas
interrelaciones impresionantes donde el
mar los bosques están completamente
repletos de seres vivos algunos
organismos como por ejemplo los
colibríes me imagino que ustedes están
bastante relacionados son medios fáciles
de encontrar aquí cerca de quito en
quito y simplemente a mí cuando yo le
veo un colibrí me maravilla ver este
pequeñísimo animal que tiene una
capacidad de vuelo impresionante y a
pesar de que muchas personas no saben
tienen un poder a lo largo de sus
procesos evolutivos de haber
influenciado también como las flores han
llegado a tener sus formas y colores
cuando pensamos en biodiversidad la
cantidad de adaptaciones que podemos
encontrar en nuestro planeta es
impresionante eso es esta flor de ahí
que es un cactus uno de los árboles más
grandes del mundo que está ahí de manera
general que es biodiversidad
la biodiversidad no es sino una forma
chiquita de decirle a un término te digo
que se llama diversidad biológica o
diversidad de vida y es un conjunto de
todos los seres vivos y sus procesos e
interacciones que existen dentro del
planeta lo interesante es que la
biodiversidad se puede reconocer que
tiene diferentes niveles uno de los
niveles es el nivel genético el otro es
la cantidad de especies y el otro son
las interacciones que se dan entre estas
especies a través de los ecosistemas
esta diapositiva refleja la variedad
genética y aquí quiero que vean esas son
unas pocas de las cientos de variedades
de papas que existen en el planeta y
aquí quiero hacerles una reflexión los
humanos dependemos enteramente de la
biodiversidad por más que nos creamos
super avanzados dependemos para respirar
el 100% del oxígeno que nosotros
respiramos es generado por la
biodiversidad y no creo que nadie como
piedras todo lo que comemos es
biodiversidad avanzando un poquito en el
tema de diversidad la diversidad de
especies todos los diferentes organismos
que se encuentran sobre el planeta y
puntualmente el tema que les quiero
contar ahora es ecuador es un país que
tiene una posición única tanto en temas
del océano en temas de la cordillera de
estar de hecho en la línea ecuatorial y
somos uno de los 10 países megadiversos
del planeta estas son fotografías
obtenidas a lo largo de años por
diferentes fotógrafos en un sitio
espectacular la estación de
biodiversidad putin y que se encuentra
en el cerca del parque nacional yasuní
donde la san francisco tenemos
estación
todos estos representan sólo un pequeño
ejemplo de los cientos sino miles de
especies que se encuentran en tiputini
y normalmente cuando nosotros pensamos
en sitios mega diversos sitios donde hay
muchísimas especies usualmente pensamos
en bosques tropicales y sí sí es verdad
esos son de los sitios con la mayor
cantidad de diversidad genética
diversidad de especies estos bosques
tropicales hoy en día están muy
restringidos y varios problemas
hacia la biodiversidad como son la
contaminación la destrucción de los
hábitats cada vez lo están los están
reduciendo más
sin embargo cuando uno piensa en
biodiversidad en pocas ocasiones uno se
detiene a pensar de que la biodiversidad
también es una parte integral de los
agroecosistemas y de los ecosistemas
urbanos esas plantas que para muchos son
malas hierbas de esos pajaritos que
andan dando vueltas por los parques son
elementos constituyentes y super
importantes de esta ecología urbana que
vive junto a nosotros
definir exactamente qué es lo urbano es
un poquito complicado no es una cuestión
de ceros y unos blancos y negros aquí
está un mapa de quito ahí a la izquierda
se ve la mancha blanca es en la zona
central urbana de quito y ahí sí es que
ustedes van viendo hacia los costados de
esa mancha se hace un poquito más difusa
y es porque las zonas urbanas como les
digo no son cuestiones estrictamente
determinadas de un mapa son más bien una
matriz que mientras más se va alejando
de los núcleos permanentes empiezan a
ver más interacciones con áreas verdes y
área de agrícolas es bien interesante la
ciudad de quito una de las ciudades
donde yo en temas ecológicos de hecho
más de investigación es la ciudad de
quito que fue fundada en 1534 miren la
fecha de este mapa no sé si le alcanza a
ver ahí abajo es mil 734 y si usted
ustedes comprarían con las divisiones
originales de la ciudad en 200 años la
ciudad no había cambiado nada seguía
siendo básicamente lo que hoy nosotros
le conocemos como el centro colonial
en este mapa está representado un poco
como a lo largo del tiempo la ciudad ha
ido cambiando y esta es una
característica bien interesante de los
hábitats urbanos es que tienen un
dinamismo muchísimo más rápido debido a
que los efectos humanos son mucho más
rápidos que en áreas prístinas y miren
como en ambos pueden ver que
originalmente el crecimiento de kito
estuvo restringido a la zona del centro
colonial pero eventualmente se ha ido
desplazando y muchos muy muy muy rápido
con una tasa superalta hacia los
costados y eventualmente incluso hacia
los valles
básicamente después de los años 60 hubo
una explosión una explosión del
crecimiento urbano de kito y áreas que
eran tradicionalmente agrícolas
empezaron a tener esta combinación como
el mismo cumbayá entre horas urbanas y
áreas rurales y naturales
esto obviamente ha provocado efectos de
los 8 ecosistemas nativos que existen o
existían en quito 2 todavía están bien
representados
4 están representados por fragmentos
pequeños cuando uno ve quebradas cuando
uno se va al pas ochoa de hecho el paso
8 es uno de los fragmentos más grandes
que todavía se encuentra bien preservada
en quito y lastimosamente dos han sido
totalmente destruidos para quien no sabe
en lo que hoy en día es la carolina más
o menos entre la iv y la zona de la
carolina
antes habían unas zonas que eran unas
lagunas y en la zona de turubamba en el
sur también habían unos pantanales esos
dos tipos de hábitats lacustre han
desaparecido básicamente por completo
miren como proyectando este mismo patrón
a nivel país vemos que entre el 2001 y
el 2010 simplemente para ubicarles el
nivel de urbanización en ecuador ha
crecido significativamente y a una tasa
muy acelerada y cada vez más acelerada
por lo tanto pensar en los ecosistemas
urbanos y la necesidad de tener
información sobre lo que está pasando en
esos ecosistemas urbanos no solo con
nosotros con los humanos sino con el
espacio y con la biodiversidad es un
tema clave ya no solo podemos seguir
pensando en biodiversidad allá en el
bosque tropical tenemos que empezar a
ver lo que está pasando en estos sitios
lastimosamente existen poquísimos datos
de lo que está pasando en los
ecosistemas urbanos ecuatorianos
básicamente no podemos responder
preguntas clave ni qué especies existen
allí todavía muchas especies que son
nuevas y que viven en hábitats urbanos
es decir son nuestros vecinos y nunca
han sido descritas para la ciencia
y lo que les quiero presentar en el tema
de ciencia ciudadana que es básicamente
la ciencia ciudadana es motivar lo mismo
que a mí me pasó cuando yo tenía 8 años
motivar a todas las personas para que
contribuyan información contribuyan a la
investigación de nuestros vecinos que
viven con nosotros de la biodiversidad
que está en nuestros alrededores no
importa que ustedes no sepan nada de
plantas nada de aves nada de bichos nada
nada el interés que ustedes tengan
simplemente en muchos casos de tomar una
fotografía y subirla a diferentes
aplicaciones hoy está ya muy moderno
pero les voy a contar que de hecho el
proyecto de ciencia ciudadana más
antiguo tiene más de 100 100 años
y hay una serie de ventajas de la
ciencia ciudadana por un lado nos ayuda
a explorar en donde vivimos
lastimosamente hoy en día esta vida
urbana super estresante nos ha limitado
a horarios ya espacios en los cuales no
llegamos a descubrir lo que nos rodea
esto es una forma de abrir ventanas
abrir puertas y es empezar a explorar lo
que nos rodea empezar a aprender sobre
lo que nos rodea empezar a ver si
realmente esa planta es una mala hierba
o simplemente le pusimos el nombre de
mala hierba porque no le llegamos a
conocer empezamos a ver que ese pajarito
que las mañanas canta empezarás a ver
que otros organismos viven con nosotros
y de hecho por lo tanto empezar a
reflexionar sobre si es que somos el
único
ser que debe ser el más importante en la
zona o si es que en nuestro quehacer
diario
deberíamos tomar consideración de que
compartimos el espacio con más seres
vivos y además toda esa información
porque imagine imagínense es de
información que cada uno de ustedes cada
ciudadano puede generar la cantidad de
información que se genera para hacer
investigación les voy a mostrar es
espectacular
hoy en día con las nuevas tecnologías
básicamente cualquier persona que tenga
un teléfono medianamente inteligente va
a poder ayudar a colectar datos para
hacer investigación y es tan sencillo
como salir a su jardín ni siquiera
tienen que irse muy lejos a su jardín a
la vereda a sitios públicos y empezar a
tomar fotografías les voy a contar
acerca de un par de aplicaciones que
sirven para esto
hace algunos años empezamos a trabajar
con un proyecto que se llama el conteo
navideño de aves mientras que para la
mayor parte de personas la navidad
normalmente implica regalos y estar con
la familia y todas las más para nosotros
también pero además hay un componente
adicional y es que solemos dedicar un
día al año para ir a contar aves
simplemente nos levantamos en la mañana
y esto es un proyecto relacionado con
entre la san francisco y el colectivo
aves quito donde hemos motivado para que
las personas empiecen a kun a conocer
más sobre lo que les rodea ahora el
inicio de este conteo es bien
interesante y ahí sí va a estar yo
positiva un poco terrorífica cómo empezó
este proyecto de ciencia ciudadana
empezó porque hace 100 años en la época
navideña en eeuu se hacía la cacería
navideña y qué es lo que se hacía se
hacía una competencia por quien mataba
más aves ustedes llegaban así podían ver
llegaba la gente con unas montañas de
pájaros muertos y ganaba el que tenía
más del que había matado más
debido a esto un científico de nueva
york- del américa misión de nueva york
le propuso a la gente de hecho esa es la
propuesta es la carta con la que propuso
le dijo miren gente porque en lugar de
estar matando aves no empezamos a verles
y la competencia es un poquito menos
sanguinaria y más bien empezamos a
conocer lo que existe a nuestros
alrededores y así es como empezaron de
hecho la fotografía
de arriba desde el primer conteo y en la
navidad de 1928 observadores 28 personas
que fuera de el científico que organizó
no sabían mayor cosa de aves habían
visto un poquito lo que había se fueron
a 25 sitios en canadá y eeuu y
registraron 90 especies hoy en día eso
ha crecido de manera exponencial hay
miles de conteos a lo largo de todo el
continente americano
lo interesante también esto me gusta
resaltar es porque el científico que
empezó esto se llama frank chapman y
tenía una cercanía grandísima con quitó
y sport con ecuador con quitó porque él
fue el autor del primer libro de aves
del ecuador y describió un montón de
especies nuevas de aves que se
encuentran solamente en ecuador casi
como receta él nos decía vean empiecen a
ver aves y particularmente cuando vino
ecuador él se dio cuenta del riquísimo
que éramos en términos de biodiversidad
hoy en día los trabajos que estamos
haciendo con aves la motivación que
estamos logrando con las personas para
que cada vez más salgan a ver aves está
dando frutos y una de las cosas a lo que
les invito es si es que hoy en de estas
iniciativas empiecen a salir de su casa
y les voy a mostrar estos gráficos son
bastante rápidos lo que se ve ahí esa
mancha que ustedes ven ahí son cada uno
de esos son puntitos de registros que
personas ciudadanos cuando salían de sus
casas dijeron le vi a esta golondrina en
esta fecha y gracias a las millones de
datos que se logran conectar
eso representa los patrones migratorios
de esa especie antes de eso tener esta
información era dificilísimo porque caso
contrario se tendría que tener a cientos
de miles de investigadores con un costo
altísimo tomando datos hoy en día la
clave es que los ciudadanos pueden hacer
eso
estos datos son de 121 especies y son
los patrones migratorios de especies que
vienen de eeuu a sudamérica y luego se
regresan a lo largo de los diferentes
procesos estacionales todo eso se debe y
esta información se debe a que tenemos
millones de datos colectados por
personas comunes y corrientes incluso
podemos proyectar en el tiempo es a cómo
se mueven las manchas aquí y ahí a la
izquierda pueden ver son proyecciones de
qué es lo que va a pasar en el futuro
podemos evaluar qué es lo que va a pasar
con problemas de contaminación problemas
de cambio climático con las especies y
esto nos da resultados para poder
manejar mejor y conservar a la
biodiversidad en ecuador este es uno de
los portales más importantes se llama
híbert y hay mil 637 especies que tienen
registros de personas es decir casi
todas las especies de ecuatorianos han
sido registrados y tienen datos de
ciencia ciudadana
hasta el momento hay 96 mil 332 listas
que han sido subidas es decir todavía
hay muchas más personas que no se han
motivado para subir y esa es mi
invitación el día de hoy
esta es una mancha que representa
el nivel de concentración de especies
observadas y miren que lo interesante es
que cerca de quito hay una significativa
un significativo incremento de esta
cantidad de datos subidos esta es otra
cosa importante la de todas las las
listas que se han subido pichincha es de
las que más tiene es decir estamos
logrando que cada vez más personas se
vinculen a empezar a hacer estas
observaciones este no sé seguramente la
han visto es un pajarito bien común por
aquí se llama el gorrión y estos son los
datos para todo el continente cada una
esas máquinas
azules y estas son las marcas de donde
han sido observados por personas comunes
y corrientes simplemente alguien cuando
le ve abre la app dice levy en algunos
casos le toman fotos otros no
necesariamente y miren como de hecho los
patrones son bien interesantes porque en
la ciudad están más o menos concentrados
a la reata velocidad pero luego cuando
uno puede ver los patrones de las
carreteras por donde la gente se va
moviendo
esta es otra base de datos esta es una
de las que a mí más me gusta se llama
anna perry list
básicamente hacen magia si es que
ustedes siempre han querido saber qué
plantas de esa que tienen la maceta y en
lion les han dado millón nombres la
clave es [ __ ] tomar una fotografía
descargar la aplicación y la aplicación
le reconoce a uno le da el nombre y el
apellido de lo que no está viendo es
impresionante
simplemente para terminar les quiero
contar que el año pasado empezamos a
desarrollar cada vez más de este censo y
hemos podido empezar a recopilar
información de que cada vez más aves
quiteñas hemos podido ver que algunas
les va mejor que a otras eso quiere
decir que los humanos si podemos dar
información valiosa no solo para saber
que hay sino para saber su estado de
conservación y por ejemplo sabemos que
algunas especies como por ejemplo estas
aves que están viendo esta se llama
mucho chin
este es un búho les está yendo mal se
están muriendo y el problema es que
recién nos estamos dando cuenta de estos
problemas
ustedes son capaces de crear esta
información de compartir esta
información de generar esta información
y realmente les invito a que cada vez y
en algunos casos incluso con arañas y
estamos comentando que la gente siga
viendo más a la vida que existe en quito
y eventualmente les inviten a sus casas
les inviten a ser parte de su vida
salgan más a los sitios y podamos
conocer más de lo que existe con
nosotros esta es una actividad que puede
relacionarla cualquier realizarla
cualquier persona de cualquier edad es
casi un ejercicio ustedes pueden salir a
caminar mientras están viendo y
colaborando para conocer más sobre lo
que está pasando en nuestro planeta
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]